estas elecciones estaban llamadas a ser
dominadas por el sector conservador y
radical esto se debe a que el consejo de
guardián de guardianes una junta de dos
expertos en ley
han venido eliminando en los últimos
años a los candidatos reformistas y
moderados un sector al que pertenece el
presidente hassan rohan y aún así los
iraníes se llevaron una gran sorpresa
hoy al saber que algunos candidatos
pertenecientes al sector moderados muy
de las entrañas del régimen como el ex
portavoz del parlamento alí lariyaní
habían quedado eliminados o también el
vicepresidente actual del campo
reformista el señor jahangir y es así
como esta lista de siete personas que
fue publicada hoy
la mayoría son conservadores radicales
solamente a un candidato del reformismo
y otro del sector moderado pero sin
ninguna oportunidad para ganar y deja
así que la lista o un solo ganador según
lo dicen las redes sociales iraníes esta
mañana se trata del jefe de la justicia
ibrahim raeissi que también fue
derrotado
hace 4 años por el presidente de hassan
roja ni y nadie piensa que vaya a tener
un contenedor y la gran pregunta hoy es
qué tanta participación habrá las
próximas elecciones